[Music]
are you already tired of social
distancing have you had enough of trying
to explain video chats to your grandma
or pretending that you're going to use
this free time to get super jacked sorry
to break it to you but with increasing
populations and climate change pandemics
are likely to become more frequent which
means that this kind of social
distancing might become the new norm
how could prolonged social distancing be
bad for your health what controversial
methods could be implemented to keep
people apart and what sort of punishment
could you face if you didn't comply this
is what if and here's what would happen
if social distancing became law
staying away from other people might not
sound too bad to some of you but over
time it can have some pretty negative
effects on your health not only can it
increase your risk of depression but it
can also lead to heart disease dementia
and death the good news is that a lot of
these negative effects can be reduced
through social contact with others no
this doesn't mean secretly meeting up
with people it means embracing all the
forms of digital communication we have
at our fingertips if connecting
digitally becomes our new normal
how would this affect the way we form
and maintain relationships the internet
allows us to stay in touch with and see
the faces of loved ones that we can't
meet up with in person if social
distancing became law these sorts of
online interactions would be important
to our physical and mental health
for example during stressful times like
these our heartbeat slows down when we
have a friend with us but even with all
the communication apps out there
technology can't replace face-to-face
interactions it's not as easy to
understand nonverbal behaviors such as
body language facial expressions and
gestures during electronic meetings plus
maintaining existing relationships
online might be easy but what about
establishing brand new ones like
romantic ones
dating while social distancing might
sound impossible but it just means you'd
have to put the physical stuff on hold
until you think they're worth getting
quarantined for that is this might slow
down the pace of dating which has been
accelerated through the use of dating
apps
no more talking for a day meeting up and
moving on now you'll be forced to take
your time with potential partners and
have the patience to get to know each
other on a deeper level maybe this would
result in a more meaningful relationship
if you're ever allowed to leave the
house again but enough about you let's
head outside and see what effects
mandatory social distancing would have
on the rest of the world for one thing
some countries would impose fines and
even prison time for people breaking
social distancing during the 2020
pandemic people in Nova Scotia Canada
could be fined up to $1,000 per day for
being in gatherings of more than 5
people because of rules like this
companies would have to get creative
with their operations especially
businesses like restaurants and gyms
restaurants could transform into
primarily drive-through and delivery
businesses but GMOs would probably have
a bigger struggle trying to survive sure
they could offer online workouts but
that wouldn't replicate the equipment
and resources that their physical
locations was offered instead people
might start to get their physical
activity through more solitary
activities like hiking surfing but there
would have to be strict regulations on
how many people could be at a specific
spot at the same time on the bright side
with all these new regulations to
enforce a lot of new jobs will be
created it would start with guards being
employed to make sure people keep their
distance but in the long term these new
jobs could come from developing new
technology to track everyone and that's
where this whole thing takes a real
dystopian turn governments could use
facial recognition technology to make
sure that you and everyone else sticks
to the rules
cell phones could even be used to set
off a blaring alarm every time you've
got within one meter of another person
eventually you could see our society
divided into different shifts to keep
large amounts of people from gathering
at once just like shift work a shift
society would mean that only people from
certain parts of the city would be
allowed to enter specific places during
set hours or on specific days some
people might work at the office on
Monday and Wednesday and others on
Tuesday and Thursday with all this
isolation people would start to develop
agoraphobia this is essentially a fear
of other people and of leaving your home
maybe this could lead to the
construction of virtual reality worlds
where everything is simulated these
worlds could be so realistic that you'd
lose sight of what's real and what's
pretend but that's a story for another